Will Ferrell is a producer of your show
and I think first of all I think he's
the funniest man on the planet Will
Ferrell and so what a great thing he's
producing your show how involved is he
he really looks out for us he comes on
the show from time to time he actually
was I'm three weeks ago and we did a bit
that I was really proud of because it
really spiraled I'm the first student it
went a little too far it was very
confusing
he came on he was our executive producer
he's like we got to get these numbers up
maybe I'm like let's drive these numbers
through the roof what do we got to do to
get more eyes on this thing and we wound
up doing this like almost like pseudo
ayahuasca ceremony where he was wearing
robes and antlers and he made me drink
this sacred tea he's like a druid and
he's doing like an invocation to get
more people to watch the show yeah
almost like an occult ceremony but it
was all fake people rubbed blood on me
and dirt on me and then I was birthed
out of a six-foot-tall vagina and it was
really either really lovely to find a
six-foot-tall vagina we built it ever
heard of vagina
referred to in its tallness yeah yeah
you know I mean thank you so much and it
was just like this dumb did we did but
we'll also commit so much so so fully
two things what thousand percent
right did you at any point were you
thinking what am i doing while this is
all happening oh absolutely I mean it
ended with him making me suckle from his
teeth while he rubbed my head it was so
weird it was so weird and I'm so proud
of it and the thing I'm most proud of I
am I'm so proud of it and the thing I'm
most proud of is that this is totally
true there's all these like online
conspiracy websites and like subreddits
and they have latched on to this thing
and analyzed it and made videos
analyzing it and they say that my show
on truTV is like a hub for a Hollywood
satanic ring and they really believe it
and they're saying Will Ferrell is
involved in all the Satanism and my show
is where celebrities go to spread their
satanic messages which I am flattered
that they think my show is that popular
yeah they're gonna
say you're a part of it because you're
talking to me they're gonna say you're
both a part of it now and they're right
and you're right the conspiracy theorist
you're right these guys are a big part
of all of this yeah yeah and they're
gonna deny it right now but I came here
today to spread the truth and II in
particular he's really laughing stuff no
I'm not I'm just not where to go
everybody knows it's the worst-kept
secret in Hollywood Andy Richter no
lieutenant goat worshipper cut it out
you